hier ist was los freunde überall
schnappatmung rechtsruck krise der
volksparteien kinder es war doch nur
eine bundestagswahl
und es gibt schließlich auch gute
nachrichten ihr in münster ist die afg
unter fünf prozent geblieben und nur in
münster aber trotzdem die heute-show
verneigt sich vor all den münsteraner
studenten die diese sensation möglich
gemacht haben ich sage oh münster meine
damen und herren
münster
[Applaus]
ja
stock des verschütteten widerstand
hier symbolisch dargestellt durch einen
etwas zu alten studenten gleichzeitig
meine damen und herren erleben wir
natürlich gerade fasziniert die
schmerzhafte steiß geburt von jamaika
jamaika kommt was soll da noch
schiefgehen
ach ja auch seehofer ja ja der dreht
jetzt endgültig frei das wissen sie und
ich sage kein wunder - 10 prozent für
die csu in bayern zehn prozent das ist
ne halbe spd katastrophe da sind jetzt
konsequenzen gefordert denn die csu hat
ja eine links flanke auf der rechten
seite eine offene flanke der seehofer
hat auf der rechten seite noch offene
flanke wenn man da nicht zum arzt geht
fängt es an zu riechen meine dame dieser
ministerpräsident steht auf der kippe
der ist offiziell angezählt oder auf
beides freunde das ist nicht übertrieben
tatsächlich gab es in der csu diese
woche und jetzt schneiden sie sich an
erste rücktrittsforderung gegen den
könig
sie sind zu recht entsetzt
und wir haben das kaum geübt meine damen
und herren offene csu revolte gegen den
vorsitzenden fast jeder jahr wegen der
demokratischen partei dabei hat der
horse doch nach der wahl das
entscheidende gesagt vielleicht sogar
ein pick so oft und wir müssen der
öffentlichkeit deutlich machen wir haben
verstanden ich sage der bevölkerung wir
haben verstanden wir sagen den
wählerinnen und wähler wir haben
verstanden dass die leute sehen die
haben verstanden wenn wir sagen wir
haben verstanden sagen wir wir haben
verstanden auch um der bevölkerung klar
zu machen
wir haben verstanden ja ich habe
verstanden dass du das verstanden hast
leider hast du original gar nichts
verstanden rechte flanke die csu ist
doch vom wähler bestraft worden weil sie
versucht hat die afg rechtsüberholen
jetzt noch mehr rechts und hier was ist
eigentlich mit der merkel ihre partei
hat doch auch massiv verloren was ist da
denn alles falsch gelaufen
höchste zeit für eine schonungslose
bilanz ich kann nicht erkennen was wir
jetzt anders machen müssten nicht wirst
du nicht wie man es noch geiler machen
sollte
aber die frau wird in sachen
selbstzufriedenheit auch immer mehr zu
helmut kohl sehen dass auch aufgefallen
verstörend muss ich sehr verstörendes
bild unter merkels führung muss jetzt
ein jahr völlig neuartiges parteien
kompott entstehen lecker jamaika ja da
kommt zusammen was überhaupt nicht
zusammen gehört das wird nicht einfach
es wird nicht einfach die kleinen
parteien platzen ja geradezu vor
selbstbewusstsein
die zweistellige fdp zum beispiel die
wahl bei der fdp die stimmung am sonntag
hier wird party gemacht rainer brüderle
ist gerade mit zwei bier an mir
vorbeigelaufen
[Applaus]
nur zwei bier was ist denn mit dem
brüderle los aber nicht gut ja gut an
der fdp behauptet ich würde jamaika am
ende ganz sicher nicht scheitern die
neuen liberalen die sind doch durchaus
kompromissbereit die haben jetzt sogar
ihre soziale ader entdeckt hier hat
jemand geschrieben alleinerziehen zwei
kinder und die sagt warum soll ich denn
oder weniger wählen weil für mich tut
überhaupt keiner was hatten die fdp da
im programm hat bei den steuern haben
wir schon ein paar ganz gute vorschläge
also wer einsteigen will zum beispiel
immobilien überlegt sich zu kaufen für
das alter da sagen wir wir wollen den
von der grunderwerbsteuer befreien
oh da freut sich die alleinerziehende
hartz 4 mutter bestimmt riesig wird sich
bei ihrem nächsten immobilie solche
vorteile genießen
danke fdp wirklich gehört und trotzdem
und trotzdem stellen wir fest verstehen
sich zumindest liberale und grüne schon
erstaunlich gut
erschreckend gut sie vereint die sorge
ums land plus das dringende bedürfnis
endlich wieder minister zu stellen man
will es möglich machen die grünen
vielleicht ein tick mehr als die fdp
weil die grünen wollen an die fettnäpfe
richtig und wenn eine partei weiß wo die
fettnäpfe stehen dann die grünen bei der
damen und herren natürlich wittern die
kleinen wie sehr merkel auf sie
angewiesen ist das ist für die cdu ein
problem
gleichzeitig haben sie aber auch angst
vor allem die fdp erinnert sich noch
allzu gut wie brutal gefährlich so eine
koalition mit mutti sein kann wenn man
das ist ja eine echte challenge